we're so close an encounter with death
we don't even know you're you're
encountered with death right now any
moment anything can happen we can die
any second yeah and when you're dying
life becomes more abusive everything you
see the tree is more beautiful
everything every time when we have the
Expedition date we're no longer gonna be
around everything looks bad the picture
is more beautiful everything people
everything's more loving you know
everything's more loving yeah I think
death has a bad rap
how could life be so beautiful and death
be bad
why would God want us to suffer yeah if
everything we we believe about God is
true which I believe too why would he
want us to suffer how can life be
beautiful and death be bad when
everything is love